[Music]
thank you
oh man look at my life I'm a lot like
you are
old man take a look at my line I'm a lot
like you are thank you
[Music]
oh man take a look at my life 54 years
of crack and stumbling around the
house cutting business deals with you
I'm lost on the songs really got my
wires crossed like when you get
completely lost
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
that last look in your eyes falling down
your pants are Brown Spending days in
such a haze and totally confused
living life completely cast look at all
the time that's passed often I'll also
fill my pants with the number two
[Music]
foreign
oh man look at my life I'm a lot like
you are
[Music]
[Applause]
remember none of this is possible
without you join the fight and sign up
for mug club today at louder with
crowder.com gain access to an unrivaled
catalog of unapologetic and entertaining
Traders including The Hodgetwins Nick
depalo Brian Kellen and of course Alex
Jones all that and everything you see
today is entirely funded by viewers like
you for 89 annually join the fight at
lottery.com Mud Club today
[Music]
[Applause]
that's what I know
[Music]
speedy questions
oh I got all of that one that one was a
good sip yummy good sip but my
headphones a little bit foggy here today
it's my fault that's my headphones I
tend to do this
I don't know why this is what I trained
for
it's a little bit more of a regular
schedule here this week last week we did
a four and a half hour live stream of
the uh the debate uh if you're going to
call it that a lot to talk about today
not to be deterred by their five
trillion dollar market cap uh loss
Target is continuing to indoctrinate
your kids
nowhere to rumble and uh hey people here
with the YouTube dump button be sure to
hit it because I will use the term
today
I want to make sure they're on their
toes we're talking about that Donald
Trump can't stop losing with the
merchandise
[Music]
I'd like to really get to today you know
obviously it's a tragedy what happened
in Jacksonville okay people say oh
thoughts and prayers are stupid you need
to ban guns shut up but I do think it's
interesting to look at the dynamic
between Nashville what happened where we
had a radical gender theorist uh and
what's happened in Jacksonville based on
the information we have someone who
probably is a disturbed you know a
mentally deranged racist
you don't live in a free country if you
have laws but if the laws are applied
equally and the same thing with the
standards of media right we kind of have
trials but we also have trial by uh by
public opinion right now and uh that's
what we're seeing with President Trump
what's the question of the day what
would president Donald Trump's former
president civil Kong setting president I
call him sitting president what would he
have to do for you to not vote for him
at this point
what would he need to do for you to not
vote for him and I don't just mean in
the primary you can vote for whoever I
mean in the general you read my mind
yeah I'll be talking about that and more
Gerald a number two how are you sir I am
doing well I'm happy to be back and this
is a normal week last week was a little
crazy but it was fun man I was trying to
bring the energy up because it's Monday
morning to NPR news update I'm doing
fine Stephen how are you did you have a
good weekend we're going today to the
Poughkeepsie Playhouse to hear this jazz
funk afro Duo that's a thing I don't
know I listen to NPR because you know I
love state-run media there you go so
you're doing well you're I'm doing fine
prickly yeah no I'm doing fine it was a
very very do you guys ever do this I had
a really really boring weekend where
because plans were kind of you know
mixed up right right so I made sure that
I just sat around the house doing
nothing so by the end I was like a caged
animal going I want to go back to work
uh-huh yeah and now I don't
and it is third chair when you hear this
you know who it is you love him he's
going to be uh this Saturday or no wait
sorry September 23rd at the Rosalind
theater in Roselyn wash Roslyn
Washington Rosalind Rosalind I don't
know you can follow him at Josh
underscore firestein on the Instagram to
see all this dates Josh how are you sir
I'm good I'm good good it's Monday
morning Gerald get excited look at you
look at him all kind of coordinated yeah
look at the fatigue Three Six Mafia
[Laughter]
dressed like
you can't find me
[Laughter]
find me you think a Target would help
but he's almost pregnant well and black
now I guess it's the disappearing rubber
I don't know I never watched we didn't
have it when I was a kid we didn't have
school in Canada no and our Oreos are
different so are our Corn Pops Canadians
comment below your Corn Pops are
basically spherical cap and crunches I
don't know why it's a silly place and I
hope that someday we nuke it okay whoa I
don't want to waste the bombs they used
to get all their weed from Canada though
and now they just get it from anywhere
yeah yeah the mystery van is unless
you're in a weed legal State I don't
know if you know this so they ban uh THC
from hemp really because I don't know if
you know big weed is always looking out
for you it hasn't evolved into another
week
no it's true there's like 11 states
where the THC from hemp is illegal uh
it's illegal from Canada legal from
marijuana and those states are states
where marijuana is legal because they
can't tax it and regulate it comment if
you guys know that and you know what
right now this is one of the few times
I'll ask if you're on Rumble go and hit
like on YouTube this week we're going to
be doing an experiment because of the
Shadow Banning so hit like on YouTube we
want to see how that affects the
algorithm just as many of you boom go
hit like then go back to rumble because
we're going to be using that dump button
a lot
because you might need to hit this for
YouTube they are coming for your
children remember when everyone said
that was a slippery slope well it's
really more of a lubed slope
because then if you have kids they
shouldn't be here watching this right we
want you to see the evil that is out
there in the world so that you can
protect your family from it this is not
a G-rated show not a trigger warning
just age-appropriate here some Philly
bike riders who uh get naked and you
know they're say from the mouths of
babes I want you to watch this until the
end and hear what little child asks and
uh you know what they're more reasonable
than the queer the queer party friends
on the bikes
[Music]
[Applause]
the only sane one of the group finish
the question below
[Laughter]
person gross that person and why are
they all gross ew and why is this man
holding a saxophone which is clearly a
two-handed instrument while trying to
ride a bicycle it's almost as though
this is disingenuous and they're all
just a bunch of illogical degenerates
right Mom
that's fair I didn't even think about
that yeah
blew my mind yeah I can see Kenny Kenny
my bicycle I mean let's it's a tandem
you can see the moment where he's like
and he has a decision to make do I want
to ride or do I want to play this thing
I don't know I'm just really gay and
talentless
I've always got a flute on me yes yes
but there was a lot of skin flute
playing there too yeah and man is also
Master of the organ I guess it's not
Always Sunny in Philadelphia sometimes
it's gloomy and full of dicks
you assume they're too fat to actually
see them so
I guess because they're ugly and naked
it's art if they were attractive it
would be pornography so that's true hey
there you go no that's appropriate hey
just take your kids to a strip club
no all right no of course of course
don't take your children to it no I'm
just saying it's just really the you
know who else is this way Ezra Miller
that guy should have to face the wall
considering what he's done and I was
reading up on him because I was forced
to watch this stupid Flash Film and I
don't know how he's ever convinced
anyway
shut up it was on it was on HBO it's
forced thank him that was a word I was
going to hone in on forced it's the
whole thing is thinking I'm running
really fast fast and I'm getting hungry
that's the whole movie and then I'm
reading up on this guy who has kidnapped
people he was of course groomed children
who are underage who has committed
violent assault breaking and entering
and I'm reading as Rolling Stone and
Vanity Fair in New York Post variety
right all of these maggots and it keeps
saying like and they were arrested he
must have like a really loyal accomplice
no it's because he's queer and uses they
them pronouns will lead with that I need
to carve up for his role grammatically
it makes no sense and by the way these
guys they they're pushing body
positivity and making sure that nudity
is just a way of life but here's an
interesting thing they canceled their
after party and what they said was well
because everybody's naked and they're
drinking it creates a lot of problems
and I'm like your whole thing goes away
at that point you can't have nudity be
part of life by the way don't don't ride
in downtown Philadelphia around all of
the the city landmarks where kids are
naked that's that's what they did this
was not out in the country this was up
you know the Rocky Steps that they go up
they ride right past there and there's
kids there with families and they don't
get a choice to say hey I don't want to
see that they don't care we're not in
the street because it doesn't affect
them but then when they hit a bunch of
poppers and shots they don't want to
their thong at the local gay bar
it's hard to have a party and uh getting
drunk with those uh with those kids
there and all those dicks you know I
mean you know it just ruins the vibe
they should ride through the hood yeah
yeah exactly let's see how that goes
that's fair if they make it out I'd let
them do it yeah by the way it's a lot
right by Meek Mill's house see how it
goes it's a live show Monday through
Friday 10 a.m Eastern where you can
watch it on Rumble and of course for
those of you listening on audio you can
uh you know listen to it on Apple
Spotify Stitcher Google pod Amazon
wherever those things are and uh you can
leave a rating there is it working now
to a man is it because it for a while it
was only uploading like every three days
yes it is working now you don't sound
confident all right yeah that's I'll get
back to you so this weekend climate
protesters because that's a thing uh
they tried to block traffic into burning
man and um they found out really quickly
that Nevada sheriffs don't don't play
that game and so uh this brings us to a
segment that we haven't done while and
it's just a protester fails
[Music]
all right here they are pulling up
it's a good old chain ourselves to
something we think is immovable
what yeah did you get that yes we all
got it back around
two
[Laughter]
hit it again he said you better move go
watch this watch
[Laughter]
[Music]
I'm not violent look we're just sitting
in the road look at the guy behind him
look at the copies like God the
ridgeline's clear
oh hell
Carl's pissed
I didn't think of whether or not someone
might need to get
to someone was delivering a baby because
I'm a selfish wench
[Music]
and by the way I love because that cup
might have been some people might argue
was a little rough I think it was
completely appropriate you can comment
below let's take a look at the cop right
there he's like okay I'll keep watch uh
and looks out into the desert yeah here
it is look at the guy in the background
he's like oh yeah I'll make sure this is
just uh safe
he has full confidence that the other
guys has it handled yeah
you could see him turn he's like
I love this because it's it's climate
protesters and I'm pretty sure that's
Tribal Police is it I'm I'm quite
certain that the Nevada Rangers are like
a Tribal Police I think they are I
watched a documentary about alien don't
worry about it there's a documentary
Bible police came up yeah the Nevada
Rangers they had to investigate it and
those guys don't around and I love
sorry about the cursing I love the uh
the the fact that some of these people
are protesting and they're gonna they're
gonna be mad about the cops and then as
soon as they find out that they're
tribal and Native they'll be like oh
well I mean they're just doing their job
you know yeah oh
[Laughter]
yeah I was Tribal Police I'm sorry seven
moon bear yeah they don't mess around
dude it was six protesters from
Extinction Rebellion uh Extinction
rebellion in seven circles they were
arrested and uh they wanted Burning Man
organizers to ban private jets and
single-use Plastics at the festival so
they're gonna hate those zip ties
[Laughter]
you want the recyclable steel let me put
it in uh perpendicular I was wrong wait
till they find out about the gasoline
they burn to burn that man just wrap my
brittle anemic wrists and plastic straws
I don't care about the turtles
remember what happened remember when the
protests were happening and people were
mad that the cops were shooting well one
man had his wife and his son were in a
burning building I believe it was
Ferguson oh yeah it might have been in
uh it might have been in Milwaukee at
that point in time and there are
unintended people need to use that road
you are a danger to people who are in an
emergency needing to use the road not to
mention you were hey these are the same
people by the way who talk about
socialism they always use those
arguments like well do you like your
roads not when you're on them
do you like your roads but you
block them by the way of course we're
talking about some that's non-rivalrous
like this is an issue with socialism
roads are something that's a valid form
of government depending how it's done in
the military it's a silly lazy argument
yet these are the people who always act
as though the roads are their own
Hit the Road Jack yes that's what I say
yes Jack and Jill yeah exactly yeah it's
just it's not so Mad Max these guys make
their entire campaign is pissing people
off we're gonna go block roads for
people who are just trying to get to
work in most cases and we're gonna go
destroy Priceless works of art to make a
point can you imagine doing anything to
piss the entire world off at you more to
try to make a point I wonder how I don't
care what their point is anymore I just
care that they don't get like I just get
to rip the hand off of the pavement
that's been glued down remember that guy
was the Chisel and he accidentally got
nicked but it's like ah it's fine
the guy the extinction
I'm like no no just keep pulling till it
comes out guys that's the he chose that
to answer your question I think they
rode there on a tandem bicycle in thongs
okay good thank God because I was afraid
they used fossil fuels together the sun
is actually pretty big a pretty big
influence of CO2 in the atmosphere like
we have to put on some sunblocks
they were dragged
they scalped them too
oh
I just ended like the Revenant okay
Target all right so this is you know
we've talked about this uh your boycotts
work when combined with buy cuts and it
works especially when it's a company
where there's an easy alternative so
Target is one of them but not to be
deterred again the theme today is they
are coming for your children very
aggressively uh a 15 I was wrong 15
billion I think I said 19 trillion but
you know it's a rounding error that's
close 15 billion billion dollar market
cap loss Target um they're back of
course to their evil ways uh this time
selling a board book called bye bye
binary oh my God that's the new book and
uh it's going to be it stores nationwide
it's what they call a board book which
was new to me I uh I know what you're
all thinking
I bet the board is spelled b-o-r-e-d
o
so remember by the way this is why this
is so important Remember on YouTube we
were suspended at one point they made us
change our title even though they're a
platform not a publisher uh regarding a
podcast that said they are coming for
your children I said you can't say that
well what about when they write books
that are marketed toward your children
just to be clear babies it seems yeah
babies so the synopsis on Target's
website I don't even know they still had
a website I know uh it says I thought
they went brick and mortar they bet
wrong it says our little bundle of joy
has arrived to dismantle gender norms
doesn't that violate child labor laws
like yeah you mean you're already
tasking an infant I don't know yeah can
they get fired from that job yeah I have
no idea are there overtime I mean this
is the thing like what what conditions
so to dismantle gender Norms a joyful
baby refuses to conform to the gender
binary and instead chooses toys colors
and clothes that make them happy you
mean like all babies it's science
this tongue-in-cheek yes but enough
about yourself board book is a perfect
tool to encourage children to love what
they love and is also a great baby
shower gift for all soon to be parents
by the way encourage what they mean is
indoctrinate what they mean is
essentially groom what they mean is to
uh propagandize and by the way this uh
obviously shouldn't be a surprise
considering it's it's released on the
heels of the horribly received Moby's
dick that Target also used and that
didn't go very well
oh
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
here they're very different the way that
they develop you see this happen and
often they will fight over for example
the pink rocking uh there's there's a
pink like it's like a like kind of like
a hippo the gray one is a rhinoceros but
it's just dull it's taupe like your
shirt it's not bright and so both the
boy and the girl fight over the one that
has the kind of rhinoceros horn and it's
pink it's not and I don't for a second
go oh that must mean they're gay no they
like bright they don't know anything
you're the one who is copy pasting your
stupid values if your child happens to
like what if you're if your son likes
Lucky Charms you think that he should be
out there in the gay pride parade with a
tandem bicycle without a seat he will if
I say he will yes that's right
applying sexual Norms to babies I got
kids I got two kids big differences
Stephen big one my son loves playing
with his penis his daughter never did
that
it's a pretty easy way to figure it out
that's where it's okay to lightly
lightly SWAT a kid
[Laughter]
like twin they will do that yeah what's
that they're very curious they're very
very curious and doesn't mean they want
it they like oh what's that that's
something that looks fun that's what a
girl will say that looks fun great it
doesn't mean that we're going to
surgically attach one
by the way this was written by Eric
garon
[Music]
it's in children's rooms I'm sorry but
that the second to last photo he looked
like a circumcised you know what yes
uh what no tell me
[Music]
women could be one too yeah Gerald he
looks like it the clown if it didn't put
it in any effort
everything kind of floats down here I
don't know I don't know oh kind of low
and by the way smash the rumble button
if you're watching this right now on
Rumble let them know that you love them
because they don't ban us and of course
mug Club will be going on what we're
doing they don't let make them like they
used to today by the way here are some
other books by this uh lovely
contributor it includes poultry Geist
Geist
poultry guys the chicken who crosses the
road is killed and wakes up in the
afterlife
because you shouldn't eat meat
[Music]
YouTube
I thought the chicken walked into an old
graveyard that the house was built on
it's going with poultry guys so I'm like
at least go that direction poultry guys
go to the afterlife you jerks I thought
the book was about somebody going to
Chick-fil-A yes say walking in a hearing
they're here
oh no they're caught in the deep fryer
he also wrote A Tale of Two Princes
about two long lost brothers who are gay
of course and by the way that that book
is recommended for seventh graders and
up and uh just in case again this is the
person writing this for Target 15
billion dollar market cap loss marketing
it towards baby infants here he is
promoting uh the tale of two homo
princes on Twitter
hey if you liked red white and royal
blue and want more then I guarantee
you'll like my young adult novel A Tale
of Two Princes Al an adult I don't think
I will I don't want anymore again rights
for Disney this is the Unholy Alliance
that you're up against with or sorry I
used to write for Disney so went from
Disney to Target that's what we call a
lateral homo yes and he's writing
children's it's interesting he's writing
books for kids that's strange also I
don't understand that story's already
been told by the Spin Doctors yes
[Laughter]
want to call me he him you better not
now yeah
I wasn't sure of the conclusion but you
laid it up
I was lost
when you when you uh By the way when you
try and buy this up bye bye binary book
at uh Target you also are given these
other choices including the pronoun book
should be two pages
the hips on the drag queen go swish
swish swish actually due to the estrogen
replacement therapy uh in the masculine
endocrine system it goes crack crack
snap and Twas the night before Pride
which by the way is pretty much the same
as every night for people who are
attending private events it involves
group sex oh oh I mean ew every creature
was stirring and dressed like that just
a very fast
not even the mouse it's a guy in a mouse
costume but this is how they do it right
they say they say no no that's not no
one's coming for your kids as a matter
of fact that's suspect that's bannable
that's bannable they're not coming for
your kids we've done the uh age
restricted or not oh yeah you don't want
to do it on YouTube we're going to do
another segment based on that at some
point here in the future I think we were
but so look I I looked and I saw the
people bought these books as well kind
of other suggestions and I thought okay
like this book is bad enough but maybe
it's a one-off it's not a one-off like
every single one of those books that we
showed in that overlay are targeted
towards children to infuse the hell out
of them right the the the the the hips
on the transgender or sorry not
transgender I'm sorry I said it the
right way the hips on the drag queen go
Swiss that's Wheels on the Bus yeah like
that's before you're three years old
think about that we have kids right now
they kind of get out of the wheels on
the bus stage pretty quickly and they go
into other things and that's so super
super young kids here's the worst part
guess who they're banking on doing this
parents because the kids can't read
these books yet it's the parents they're
banking on white Suburban mothers let's
be clear yes read to the kids yes but if
that's not child abuse I don't know what
it is hips on the drag queen go swish
swish Swish and the teacher goes
exactly
it's like your kids are almost better
off not reading the book not even
reading a book I know ever I never
thought that I would say you better hey
you better close that book and go watch
death wish
yeah
last thing I want is your face in one of
those school books go lift up a few
Barbie doll skirts see what happens
nothing there my son plays with Barbies
yeah a lucky place I'm so sorry he plays
with the little boobies
my friends like are you worried about
your son playing with Barbies I was like
I don't think he's doing it wrong
I think he's nailing it yeah
and ruin his life as a future Casanova
what kind of parenting do you do in your
household her outfits don't match I'm
like he's nailing it dude because he
doesn't care for his third birthday I
got him a poster of Salma Hayek
ooh From Dusk Till Dawn style Salma
Hayek she's a pretty lady she's a
beautiful woman shut up
speaking of beautiful bye the new mug
shot uh Donald Trump of course you know
this has happened last week but he was
arrested in Fulton County and here's the
thing it's like the left they just
people talk about 11d Chess you don't
need to play 11d chess you just need to
think one or two moves ahead yeah
because the left was in Glee
at no point considering that maybe this
mug shot might backfire here's them
celebrating it's an image never before
seen in American history a mug shot of
former president Donald Trump released
overnight by the sheriff's office in
Fulton County Georgia so as a teenager
living in New York I've said it before
this because I never watched The
Apprentice I despise Donald Trump
because he to me signified the rich
white guy in Manhattan that absolutely
hated and despised you signified
and
[Applause]
look right now I mean you can just hit
the like button or a comment again
because we're trying to test the YouTube
algorithms if you're there right now I
honestly think the mug shot is pretty
badass yeah it is yes I mean think
Johnny Cash right how badass he was made
out to be just given the finger right
you have all these I mean Mel Gibson's
mugshot is out there there are some that
are okay not great and then there are
some you gotta go man I want to party
with that guy so Donald Trump turned the
tables tweeted out the mug shot himself
yeah and he tweeted out uh or X Out
sorry election interference Never
Surrender
look bad in his mug shot no he nailed it
that was a fantastic job by the way the
interactions on that were through the
roof yes look at this guy
I mean immediately by the way turned it
into merchandise including Shirts Mugs
decals Koozies which pop scratter must
be thrilled with I don't know why he has
a koozie everywhere he's like five in
his car and he also has him in his
kitchen and he just you he just puts
them on cups he puts them on tumblers
that don't even need it because does
your dad do that I love I love you but
it's like I know for sure if he's going
somewhere like hey today we are we are
offering a complimentary because he say
no more sign me up I am filling out the
survey in the back of this receipt you
can never have enough he likes the
softness and it's like shocks yes yes
[Laughter]
seven million dollars is what he's
raised since the mug shot I guarantee
you it's tens of millions if you're
looking at the cottage industries out
there that are selling his mug shot on
merchandise oh yeah well just to kind of
support he's getting from it I mean
everybody sees it for what it is but
they see fight in his eyes a huge fire
in his eyes and here's the thing I would
like for you to guess where do you think
this is going to backfire the biggest
for Democrats take a guess don't you
guys know but don't lead to no
mm-hmm
I don't know if you know this but a lot
of black Americans like people who
aren't going in as snitches they like
people who share some of that experience
and this is It's backfired so bigly at
the hood is now uh going all in for
Trump
from the land of the Irish Spring
Dublin's the place
come to do no good left in the hood come
to do no good sorry that was the wrong
clip and by the way I'll give you that
one that film is intensely racist Lap In
The Hood yeah
that's the wrong clip but uh here's a
montage of of course people in the Black
American some people say
African-American I don't
here's a montage Donald Trump's getting
ground so black people
if you really want to set these
races demons and Devil's all
vote for Donald Trump
black people forgave them I'm like this
are y'all back with Trump just like that
huh he was like he was like hell yeah
they were passing out money
I'm like damn you're crazy Trump is a
brother now I'm sorry you go to you go
you go to jail in zone six Atlanta
you're a brother
straight up
said van Jones
I prediction and you guys can comment uh
here below I think he's going to
I think Donald Trump if he is the
Republican nominee will get more black a
higher percentage of black votes the
Republican party than any Republican uh
in the last 40 years just to be clear I
think he did by the way he improved uh
by four from 2016 to 2020 we don't
really have the context but in some
areas he won a significant portion of
the black vote now I know that that
doesn't really win elections because
black Americans only make up 12 13 of
the population but uh it's important to
see the cultural shift black Democrats
and they do largely vote Democrat are
the moderate wing of the democratic
party today and this is a way to turn
them off really quickly you you act like
you side with them in defunding police
which by the way a lot of them have more
positive views of their local police in
their neighborhood that's an important
that's an important component here to
take into the equation but they have a
negative view of the federal police they
have a negative view of the
militarization of police so it's not so
much that they hate that Darren Wilson's
of the world even though he was
ostracized in the media by largely white
liberals it's that they hate people who
would for example be involved with this
mug shot in Donald Trump yeah so wrong
wrongful prosecution stuff like that by
the way Donald Trump gained support in
the black community because he didn't
just talk to the black community or talk
at them he actually did things that
helped the black community yeah the
things that all of these other people
these shills out there will talk about
but never actually do anything for
because they want to constantly have
that for elections that's it yeah that's
all he did it was simple oh right now
here really quickly let's go to CNN
where they're saying Donald Trump
campaign says it raised 7.1 after
Georgia booking let's see what they have
to say in dollars since Trump
surrendered at the Fulton County Jail
the day after his arrest was the highest
grossing day for his campaign what
happened to all your celebrations
strategist for the Romney presidential
campaign
the conspiracy to end America five ways
my old party is driving the waste of
space strategist Stuart welcome and good
morning you know part of that big
fundraising pull is the the mugshot
merchandise that his team has put out
that Trump's team has put out is there
from your perspective a Tipping Point
where the mounting legal problems start
to negatively impact oh that's wishful
thinking think of that is there a point
where we're gonna make it stick I think
we have to look at it in two different
universes a universe of Republican
primary voters and the universe of the
rest of us
um oh I think so you're not a republican
anymore okay yeah exactly Republican
primary voters
told that there is a conspiracy against
them that there is a deep state that uh
their votes were stolen okay so hold on
a second this is the kind of Republican
they bring on CNN just to be clear it's
like it's a human walking straw man just
to be clear I mean
[Music]
thank you
I have now of course admittedly not been
nearly as effective as we thought and
certainly come with more complications
they believe that their votes may have
been stolen oh I wonder why that would
be considering that some people showed
up to vote let's just use Arizona for
example and they couldn't vote for four
or five hours Let's just use that as an
example or the fact that they had
ballots sent to places where they didn't
live or their state violated the
Constitution and they believe that there
is a deep State I wonder why they might
believe that there was a deep State
considering for three years of their
lives they heard you talk about as the
Republican that you are and Anna Navarro
they heard you talk about Russia Russia
Russia collusion which we now know
beyond any shadow of a doubt is
verifiably false and was planted by
political oppositions people people like
Hillary Clinton Fusion GPS the steel
dossier for crying out loud his campaign
was actually spied on you have Americans
by the way with let's go back to Barack
Obama where the IRS was weaponized
specifically against people who were
members of the Tea Party group so why
would Americans believe that the deck is
stacked against them that maybe their
vote doesn't count as much as they
thought it would or that the government
has a deep State yeah let's just
Gaslight you and hope that that
continues to work by the way do you like
any of those ratings CNN and Fox News
let's toss you in it too
the demo numbers on Fox news people are
tuning out because you suck nothing you
say is honest you can't keep pissing on
people's forehead tell them it's not
raining tell them it is raining I don't
know the expression I don't care that
angered you tell him it's raining there
you go it's peace it's not raining it's
your piss is my point I'm pissed now I
love that this guy's the former Chief
strategist for the Romney presidential
campaign now look I understand like you
win some you lose some that was a
disaster no you just lose some no no
always loses I'm just saying with the
presidential campaign fine you know if
you're the chief strategist sometimes
it's not you it's the it's the guy that
you know you're working for it was you
he was doing very very well until you
got in his ear and said hey don't go
after Barack Obama so much in the next
debate because you just killed him
everybody loved him she's begging she's
like if they're a Tipping Point is there
a Tipping Point where all of this will
finally stick nope it just keeps he's
like Michael Myers he just keeps coming
how do we stop this well I don't know it
might help if we all stopped being such
but then again I'm not a public
Foreign
County or Atlanta yeah Atlanta Detroit
was a big was a big one that's the
awesome thing about Detroit you know
Detroit actually he was winning Donald
Trump was winning Wayne County by the
way by the same margin that he was
actually uh outperforming himself in
other urban areas meaning like if you go
to Philadelphia meaning if you go to
Portland meaning if you go to Los
Angeles I shouldn't say winning but he
was receiving a huge portion of the vote
in Wayne County with Urban voters by the
way in the same proportion that Donald
Trump was receiving them in all other
urban areas until there was a vote
switch at three in the morning when some
red wagons came in and 99 of the votes
were for Biden just this is one thing
too when you're talking about and
someone can bring this there from the uh
from Mission Control we have this in one
of our older episodes that may have been
removed from YouTube again here's what
matters is you look at major cities
across the country and Donald Trump was
outperforming the polls and he was
outperforming his previous performance
meaning he was gaining ground like we
saw when black voters like we saw with a
lot of inner city voters except for
cities which cities places like Phoenix
places like Detroit places like Atlanta
in other words Port overperformed right
Seattle over performed Los Angeles San
Diego
Tampa Miami Chicago not saying he was
winning it but he was performing by a
significantly higher margin some of
these areas he was winning until in
these key swing States
it's a statistical anomaly now that
could be the case that's not necessarily
proof but we lived it you can go back
and watch the 12-hour stream that night
in election we went to bed thinking well
I guess Donald Trump wins Michigan and
the reason why was because we were
looking at how he won Wayne County or
sorry we were looking at how he
performed in Wayne County comparing with
Kent County in Michigan a place where I
was living at that point in time during
that first election I said well look
based if we're just looking at this this
is the county that he has to worry about
and he's doing far better here and
comparable in a lot of the counties that
he won so there's really no way and we
went to bed one hour later we had to
start streaming again because the votes
flipped but hey why would Americans
think that their vote doesn't count CNN
when will our lives start working a lot
of these people already feel
marginalized too then this happens yeah
by the president who told them if you
don't vote from a UA black yeah the
president who when he was a Senator made
a bunch of laws that put a bunch of
black people in prison by the vice
president who did the putting in prison
as a D.A you know what's changed with
Donald Trump and black people were doing
this black and white on the gray issues
we'll have another one coming out this
week or later this week they always used
to think that the system was unjust and
by the way the justice system is it's
screwed up I'm going to tell you this is
not we are not in the country right now
where where Justice is often served
especially in the court of public
opinion but black Americans used to view
it as white black and Donald Trump
opened their eyes to it's it's really
about the corrupt and the people who
they don't want to be involved it's
about the people pulling the strings
it's about the Haves and the have-nots
as far as power not just money and so
now they've transitioned from the system
is corrupt
from you know against black people by
white but they're seeing the most one of
the most powerful white men in the world
go through the same kind of that
their buddy did or their cousin who was
selling weed on the corner and they go
maybe it's not a black white thing maybe
we can link arms with other white people
Asian people who've been gamed by the
system that's the kind of those are the
kinds of inroads that are being made and
that's why you can come back and I think
that if Donald Trump is a nominee he is
going to receive a record number of
black votes because again being around
in comedy we're we have the luxury of
being around generally speaking far more
black people than most white people do
right you're in a green room if you're
doing a showcase set it's like 40 black
comedy has a lot of and they're usually
better than white Comics it's like
boxing if I have to pick one and I don't
even know them the black guy's probably
better if it's comedy
I think it's better as an audience sorry
white people that's an audience I prefer
the black people oh yeah uh they're more
fun they they take a take a joke they
don't get offended they write your jokes
for you well they just say it out loud
that's because I'm a hack
wow hamburger
Burger ah come on don't do hamburger
like that
okay so this brings us to the main
segment today uh and sorry I went off on
a little bit of a rant there I just I
like it I hate the media so much yes
Jacksonville the shootings we want to do
a segment here uh comparing Jacksonville
to Nashville both tragedies
you can comment below before pause it
don't cheat it if you're not watching
this live
what you think the contrasts are
um so to set this up of course a man
killed three people uh it's tragedy of
of unbelievable proportions it's always
said uh Jacksonville yesterday and just
to be clear we already know a lot but
for those of you who maybe haven't been
recapped your ego this afternoon a
little after 1 pm an individual we have
not yet officially identified
enter idolatry in a new town area of
Jacksonville outfitted with a tactical
vest armed with the AR style rifle and a
handgun
then the shooter killed three people
before turning the gun on himself taking
his own life
other than the three individuals killed
and the shooter himself there are no
additional people who suffer gunshot
wounds
we are not identifying the deceased
victims at this time but I can tell you
that there are two male victims and one
female victim all all of the deceased
victims are black the Clay County
Sheriff's Office who has been assisting
our agency with this investigation
received information after the shooting
that the shooter had authored several
manifestos
one to his parents one to the media and
one to federal agents
portions of these manifestos detail the
shooters are disgusting ideology of hate
playing me put
this shooting was racially motivated and
he hated black people he wanted to kill
this isn't the first public State that's
one and only time I'll use that word the
weapons that the shooter used today are
a Glock and AR-15 style rifle
all right so you guys can go and watch
the whole clip and by the way all
references are available at ladder with
creditor.com and again is the rule of
law or I guess I should also say are the
ethical standards of media because it's
never been more applicable than how
often have you heard them say well we
don't want to we don't want to create
copycats so we're not even going to
address the manifesto right there the
very first statement so is
the are the ethics of Journalism applied
equally well let's compare this to the
Nashville shooting from March and we
actually still don't know things uh
there that some would argue could be
pivotal which brings us to this week's
installment of then and now
[Music]
okay so it happened last March uh so
some of you may have forgotten so let's
kind of make sure that we refresh your
memory let's go back to then
uh you have that there uh yeah I'm
looking for the next clip they added
that Leighton didn't tell me oh do you
have the clip oh nice I gotta grab it
real quick can someone grab it uh really
quickly or just
all right we're gonna try this as though
we're not live okay
the Nashville shooting which brings us
back to then
[Laughter]
I got the clip okay uh the shooter's
motive ideology we're completely
obfuscated if you remember yeah in the
early reports I've seen interviews with
you where you say that you think the
motive here was resentment what do you
mean by resentment what does that mean
resentment about what
so so the investigation is still ongoing
into uh this whole incident but what
detectives have said so far is there
there's possibly some resentment for
having to go to that school uh there's a
connection uh with that family uh right
now I can't go deeply into that uh but
because it's unconfirmed yeah here's the
very clear answer which by the way we
were able to confirm um and we're not we
don't even have an investigative unit
this was someone who was a radical
gender ideologist who was targeting
specifically what they viewed as a
Christian School in Christian victims
should be a pretty damn clear answer and
you had a Manifesto that laid all of
that out yes which we have never had
access still though right still yeah
wasn't it a woman festo well it was a z
festo it was a your guess is as good as
mine
that's my favorite comedian from the
Bonville days old Fisto
Fisto the clown
and the blame was then back in the media
immediately deflected towards what
towards what trans hate right so here's
NBC uh on March 28th fear pervades
Tennessee's trans Community amid focus
on Nashville Shooters gender identity I
don't know fear should maybe permeate
the community from crazy transgender
[Music]
thank you
Target now it's Audrey Hale for those of
you forgotten and by the way we would
have to go around we'd have to avoid on
YouTube
covering anything from the manifesto or
from this person's social media or by
the way people would be suspended on
social media in case you don't remember
for misgendering the mass shooter
here's overlay D5 in case you forgot it
was Audrey hale used he him pronouns she
did huh yeah she did I don't care not
fooling anybody YouTube dump button for
whoever's in the YouTube dump button
today
it's like Morse code
it's like that Benedict Cumberbatch film
which brings us to now
with Jacksonville
within 24 hours we know almost
everything there is to know about the
shooter including romantic preferences
and favorite meals early 20s
white male
no he targeted a certain group of people
and that's black people that's what he
that's what he said he wanted to kill
and um that's very clear just to be
clear it is equally disgusting to me for
an individual to shoot black people
because they are black
as it is for a crazy transgender
individual to shoot Christians because
they believe in biology
and by the way the FBI
[Music]
a federal civil rights investigation and
we will pursue this incident as a hate
crime
hate crimes are always and will always
remain a top priority for the FBI
because they are not only attack on a
victim they are also meant to threaten
and intimidate an entire community
well it's not hate crime that's
terrorism what we might say there Gerald
the guy's dead yeah that's what are you
investigating yeah who
what in the hell are you doing are they
investigating what what balloons for the
celebration party yeah if that was my
family was shot in a Dollar General I
wouldn't be worried about what kind of
crime it's being classed yes you shot
I'd be worried my brother and my
sister's dead that's what I'd be worried
about ah thank you FBI for coming in and
doing this as a hate crime the uh the
purpose over there with half his head
gone he should have done that before he
went into the Dollar General but hey
didn't happen what are you gonna do yeah
isn't your job too like aren't you
supposed to help prevent criminals from
shooting people not afterwards go oh
that guy's dead
what purpose do you serve
ties for this guy
real metal cuffs
the mainstream headlines less than 24
hours after the shooting
level people killed this is from ABC in
racially motivated shooting at Dollar
General in Florida this is from the
Atlantic the Jacksonville killer wanted
everyone to know his message of hate hey
this is all True by the way same thing
with the transgender shooter in
Nashville Sheriff provides the first
details of how a white man fatally shot
three black people at a Florida store
and that headline by the way from AP was
then changed to Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis booed at vigil as hundreds more
and more racist Killers oh they were
just trying to fit racist and Governor
DeSantis into the same headline someone
sat there and said okay hold on a second
I'm gonna headline here is going to be
uh Sheriff provides the first details
okay of how a white man fatally shot
three black people at a Florida store
wow that's great then his boss as
Jameson came in said that title sucks
they go on I got better uh Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis booed at vigilance
Hogwarts more and more racist killings
that's good for our country right then
hey next we'll do a segment bitching
about division and how algorithms on
social media push people to radical
ideologies I'm a piece of
that's the inner monologue that's good
comment below if you see the
inconsistency they want you to believe
that our response is what's dividing
America and unlike AP hey guess what we
make all the references available I
highly encourage that you go and watch
that you go and read them by the way
watch this show and then tune out
tune out you don't need to be scrolling
on social media every single day this is
the problem with algorithm culture so
this brings us back to then
with Nashville the manifesto was not
released oh oh right the national
appearance specifically requested not to
release the manifesto hold on why do we
give a damn what they requested were
these appearance of the victims or the
parents well the shooters the parents
can someone clarify I want to make sure
they have this important that's right it
says there's no compelling State
interest in giving voice to a horrendous
criminal the parents attorney wrote in
these documents parents of the victims
parents of the victims now listen I I
care about what they say but I'm sorry
it does it does sorry it does matter to
us we need to understand this because
right now what you're seeing is white
supremacy white supremacy white
supremacy and this guy was a white
supremacist by every account that we
have and that should absolutely be a
horror Jacksonville person this Jackson
right now we're talking about Nashville
but back into Nashville we need to know
what the motivation was yeah well we
know the media doesn't the media acts as
though they don't and by the way both
the left and the right wing media they
were claiming and here's the thing too
just to be clear I get that I'm a
hypocrite I understand because I used to
say you know what I don't want these
issues to be politicized guess what
that's not me anymore it's not me
anymore before the bodies even assumer
it's not it's not a luxury that we have
do you guys do you guys feel the same
way you can comment below hit like if
you think it's important to just push
back right away fight like hell
immediately I used to say let's wait and
we should wait for the facts yeah but
I'm not going to wait and allow them to
use the graves of children or adults
in order to try and push an agenda it's
it's no longer an option they want you
to think that everyone in this room is
responsible for the division in America
no it's them what they want to do is
divide America and have no response and
we're not going to play that game
anymore back then with Nashville both
the left and the right wing media they
were claiming that releasing the
manifesto or even talking about it even
mentioning his name would spur copycat
Killers this Manifesto lets other people
read it and then somehow copycats become
involved and the main thing you were
talking about is this called mass
shooting contagion and it's when the
releases of manifestos then contribute
to the other manifestos some people even
copy and paste the manifestos into it
and it's again it's a copycat you get
people who are doing copycat uh things
they see all the attention these things
get in the media and they're mentally
unbalanced and and uh they they go about
this business possible motive there is a
Manifesto now I'm sure there'll be all
sorts of debate whether this Manifesto
should be made public I would hope not I
don't think we want to be incentivizing
any more Behavior like this we saw with
the Christchurch shooting that Manifesto
not not be published and I think that is
a sound move okay so that was and they
didn't even want to discuss it which
brings us to now in Jacksonville though
it hasn't officially been released
um mayor loose lips sinks ships here
Donna Deegan in Jacksonville laid out
pretty much the entire shudo's manifest
the entire Manifesto of the shooter I
just said shooter like Japanese that's
what it's a Japanese fighting
organization laid out the shooter's
Manifesto in a press conference like to
the letter too often the same folks and
this type of of hate you know this type
of you see the the swastikas on the gun
this as you know was the anniversary of
uh when we had the shooting at the
landing and I believe that was also
indicated in the in the manifesto that
he was aware of that she looks if
Marjory Taylor green were raisin
dry it up
so I have been to many gun shows yeah
many gun ranges I have never once seen
someone with a swastika through you know
a Sharpie or white out on their firearm
they're not gun culture people no it
seems a little weird but where's the
fear of uh of copycats Now where's the
fear of CopyCat white supremacists
because apparently according to Joe
Biden that's the largest threat to the
United States right now the domestic
threat apparently is white supremacy and
so why I'm conf can we just pick a lane
one way or the other either we never
release the manifestos or comment on
them which is what's happening right now
or we always do I think I think now we
always will I think you I used to not
want to because of copycats but at this
point I think it's important for you to
know where you know the violence is
stemming from from where I think that's
I think that's important because we're
at a point now where you deserve to have
all the information at your fingertips
to keep yourself safe what do they just
hand you something important well they
showed the gun at the press conference
too you know with with obviously that
with the swastikas and stuff on there
yeah that is the laziest swastika I've
ever seen they're not even good yeah I
mean I just you know look I have no we
don't have enough information but this
is the problem when you only provide
information uh for some shootings and
not for others that's how you breed
conspiracy theorists because they're
going we're definitely not being given
the whole truth why because you refuse
to tell us the truth about Nashville
also this could maybe be
sort of an admission uh to the fact that
transgender individuals of course
suffering from higher rates of mental
instability are more likely to be
influenced to be a copycat whereas white
supremacy is intensely unpopular
this brings us back to then with
Nashville
the media by the way censored coverage
of the shooter across the board that
defy defied their narrative so here's
CBS Executives right they barred the use
of the word transgender so the shooter's
gender identity has not been confirmed
by CBS News although it was confirmed by
the rest of Earth
as such we should avoid any mention of
it as it has no known relevance to the
crime except for the fact that the
person said I'm committing this crime
because I'm a chick who wants to be a
guy
wait hold on a second why are you
committing this crime because I'm
transgender and I want ciscom to die um
I don't know I we need to call in
Colombo
could be pulling the old blatant
confession trick
uh of course another person was dead I'm
talking about everything that they wrote
which we went through their social it
was not hard to find it says should that
change we can and will revisit oh well
CBS when did you revisit
the wake of the shooting
people were reporting on the trans day
of Vengeance right that was something
that was going on that was planned they
were also banned from social media just
to be clear in case you've forgotten
this trans day of Vengeance was a day
that was planned on April 1st I believe
uh that year yeah uh which would have
been right when did the shooting occur
in in Nashville I know it occurred in
March in March yeah so it would have
been right after that shooting and we
had been following a lot of these groups
by the way we have investigative
journalists now we have an entire Wing
please do consider supporting mug Club
lottoscutter.com mug Club that's the
only way we can actually expand our
investigative journalism and there were
a lot of people calling for you can
bring it up there to a man there were a
lot of people who were calling for
violence just to be clear there were a
lot of people calling for violence for
the trans Dave engines and one person
went out and committed it now I think
that's relevant because I don't believe
that there was a call for violence on a
day at Dollar General against black
people tragic crime
but again isolated incident is is very
different from mobilizing galvanizing a
group of people under the banner of evil
this brings us to now Jacksonville
again because there's Nashville and
Jacksonville big Tech they can't shut up
they can't shut up about the shooters
race and or sex gender in terms of what
is driving this
just epidemic we have to talk about the
hate and and how words matter when it
comes to that law enforcement officials
say the shooter is a white male in his
20s who is motivated by hate this is one
of the two weapons that was in
possession of the white gunman in
Jacksonville Florida on Saturday when he
shot and killed three black people at a
Dollar General Store white male white
gunman white man Caucasian man when we
go back to Nashville and here's the
thing white man look doesn't really
narrow things down that's a lot of
people that's one would argue the
largest demographic in this country
um insane female to male transgender
individual hell bent on shooting
innocent people hey you know what that
gives that Clues to sin a little bit
better especially if it coincides with a
planned trans day of Vengeance ah yes I
see the connection now that you're
making by the way you know what they're
not really talking a whole lot about
this this shooter the white supremacist
because that's exactly what he was he
was a white supremacist he's an idiot
Jacksonville Jacksonville of course yeah
everything we know says this person's a
piece I'm glad that he is no longer
wasting oxygen on her absolutely also
had incredibly bad mental health
challenges had actually been I think not
committed necessarily I can't remember
what it was evaluated maybe the right
term before for mental health issues so
it's not just because they what they
want to do is they want to focus on the
one thing that they think will get
people to get oh I can't believe it
white people are coming after black
people I knew it every single time right
they don't want to go hey this mental
health thing that we've been championing
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
gosh firestein is going to be uh where
are you going to be on September
September 23rd Roslyn Washington
yep the Dollar General in Rosner Roslyn
Theater in Roswell Washington September
23rd it's cool theater it's intimate
we'll get intimate we'll have some fun
there's Mountain Focus also they don't
have a Dollar General it's a Dollar Tree
so you're golden yeah and uh
continue the show here for another full
hour if you have not joined up again
what do you get when you get mug Club
you get this you get another full hour
of the show you get Nick depalo Monday
through Thursday you get Alex Jones on
Friday you get a Friday show you're
about to get the hottest ones you're
about to get Brian Kell and you support
the investigative journalism unit and
other super videoscredit.com if you're
watching on Rumble right now just click
that button will be taking your chat
just click it click it and you join up
and we're about to play they don't make
them like they used to YouTube piss off
Rumble thank you
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]